Yvelines environnement qui fête donc
c'est 30 ans fondé en 1983 son objectif
n'a pas changé défendre l'environnement
dans tous ses aspects au plan notamment
de l'urbanisme de l'architecture de la
protection des sites bâtiés naturels
ainsi que la promotion et de la qualité
de vie c'est l'article premier des
statuts donc de cette association vous
êtes donc la présidente 30 ans d'action
déjà même si c'est assez vaste est-ce
qu'on peut faire un bilan un petit peu
de tout ce que vous avez réussi à
accomplir bien sûr alors on peut faire
un bilan certaines choses hélas sont
négatives car nous n'avons pas toujours
obtenu ce que nous souhaitions notamment
en matière d'urbanisme à travers les
plumes les différentes documents si vous
voulez qui existent aujourd'hui et puis
je crois des actions positives en faveur
notamment des scolaires et je voulais
apporter notre 23ème cycle d'éducation à
l'environnement car là aussi nous avons
pensé que l'environnement était quelque
chose que l'on devait apprendre et dès
le plus jeune âge il y avait des
effectivement savoir jeter le papier
dans la bonne poubelle la canette dans
une autre poubelle tous ces éléments les
bons réflexes
si vous voulez aussi autre chose qui a
l'air toute bête se brosser les dents ou
prendre une douche au lieu de laisser la
douche indéfiniment ouverte et bien la
fermer et on peut très bien se brosser
les dents en mettant de l'eau dans un
verre ce qui en consomme beaucoup moins
voilà des petites choses si vous voulez
des petits gestes simples que nous avons
nous avons obtenu aussi un certain
nombre de classements de sites si vous
voulez pédagogie auprès des plus jeunes
mais peut-être aussi parce qu'on va
parler effectivement du concours pour
lequel vous avez principalement ce soir
mais sur certains sur les grands
dossiers est-ce que les villes
environnement pèsent justement sur les
grandes réalisations peut-être dans le
département alors les grands dossiers
nous avons la chance je crois parce que
Yvelines environnement c'est avant tout
une équipe il ne faut pas croire vous
avez la serviette de m'inviter mais je
ne suis pas seule et seule je dirais
Évelyne environnement n'existerait pas
et je crois que c'est une équipe nous
avons eu la chance de retrouver autour
de nous des personnalités compétentes
différentes tout à fait différente des
membres de l'INRA d'anciennes personnes
du CEA des informaticiens si vous voulez
toute une équipe qui chacune dans sa
spécificité
œuvre nous avons aussi des ornithologues
tout à fait célèbres nous avons aussi un
ami qui a créé ce livre sur la flore des
Yvelines qui est une référence pour
voilà et donc je crois que c'est cette
équipe qui a permis si vous voulez les
avancements et nous sommes en général
étant que nous sommes une association
reconnue d'utilité publique nous sommes
en général consultés dans les grandes
commissions départementales vous étiez
venus aussi récemment sur ce plateau
pour parler du dossier de l'éolien
puisqu'il y avait un grand plan lancé
par la région sur l'implantation de ces
éoliennes un petit peu partout vous avez
réussi pour l'instant
on avait le sentiment parce que vous
dénoncez
les notions nous dénoncions par manque
si vous voulez d'informations sur
certains points qui nous semblaient
essentiels et notamment l'impact sur le
paysage qui nous semblait capital et de
les réserves qui pouvaient être faites
en abord de site classés et là nous
sommes très fiers de dire que nous avons
obtenu que le ministère modifie
effectivement un prennent un amendement
en disant qu'il ne pouvait pas avoir
d'éolienne dans à moins de 1 km d'un
site classé donc ça on est un exemple
concret d'une des réalisations que vous
avez pu obtenir grâce à une
environnement alors une réalisation que
nous avons nous exemples
nous avons nous avons travaillé sur le
classement de la vallée de la Bièvre sur
le classement de la plaine de Versailles
sur la forêt de protection des boîtes
phosphore voilà des dossiers sur
lesquels pour lesquels nous avons
collaboré sur le dossier du Grand Paris
Express peut-être aussi parce que
gouvernement doit rendre ses arbitrages
la semaine prochaine c'est un dossier
qui a été lancé sous le précédent
gouvernement sous Nicolas Sarkozy qui
souhaitait développer ce métro de
banlieue à banlieue il passerait par 50
ans en Yvelines par le plateau de Saclay
également pour relier un petit peu les
différents pôles économiques tout à fait
quel impact sur l'environnement vous y
êtes vigilant alors nous sommes très
vigilants bien sûr nous sions aussi dans
dans cette commission et nous sommes
très vigilants à ces points et
effectivement il est extrêmement onéreux
dans cette région qui est aussi peuplée
si vous me le permettez de faire passer
un transport en commun car effectivement
cela implique sur le plan de
l'environnement un certain nombre de
précautions qui nous sommes essentiels
et qui rendent effectivement
ce parcours plus onéreux que s'il
passait simplement à travers chant mais
à travers chant même on pense que si
vous voulez il est destructeur en
matière d'agriculture oui parce que vous
voyez aussi au respect de ce plateau de
Saclay qui pour l'instant forcément
parlé
dans le département entre entre les
Yvelines et les sols je pense que c'est
encore un espace vert si vous me
permettez si on parle de cette fameuse
trame verte et bleue dont on avait
beaucoup parlé autrefois et dont on
reparle aujourd'hui et tant mieux je
dois dire que c'est un élément essentiel
pour cela et nous souhaitons bien
évidemment dans la mesure du possible
que cela soit conservé vous êtes venu ce
soir pour nous parler non pas du Grand
Paris même si vous le faites forcément
très très bien mais vous êtes venu nous
parler de ce concours on parlait tout à
l'heure de la pédagogie de ses actions
qui sont menées auprès des plus jeunes
pour tout de suite acquérir les bons
réflexes comme éteindre ce robinet
lorsqu'on se lave les dents ce qu'on
répète souvent mais ce qui est pas
toujours forcément très enfourné vous
êtes venu parler donc de ce concours
nouvelle édition 23e édition alors 24e
24e cette année 24e édition donc nous
avons considéré là aussi que nous
devions apporter un élément aux enfants
pour leur apprendre ce qui était
l'environnement
et nous avons créé cette ce cycle
d'éducation à l'environnement en liaison
je dois dire avec le ministère de
l'Environnement le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale bien sûr le
département le conseil général qui
depuis toujours nous soutient comme les
divers ministères et nous abordons
chaque année un thème cette année c'est
le thème de la rivière nous avons abordé
le thème des abeilles nous avons abordé
le thème des oiseaux migrateurs et des
zones humides nous avons
abordé un certain nombre de thèmes aussi
le paysage qui est un élément important
et nous espérons à travers si vous
voulez ce cette petite grille que nous
faisons cette petite grille donc c'est
un concours pour les pour les 5 15 ans
il faut récupérer ce petit fascicule que
vous aviez entre les mains auprès des
gars SNCF et notamment étant donné que
nous n'avions pas de point de
distribution puisque nous sommes tous
bénévoles et c'est la SNCF qui est notre
relais et effectivement on peut
récupérer ces petits bulletins dans
toutes les gares SNCF du département il
faut répondre et alors
allez-y
commencez à répondre si vous voulez le
but n'est pas de rendre très difficile
ce document mais au contraire que tout
cette envie d'y participer et d'autre
part nous avons aussi un autre
partenaire qui sont les nouvelles et les
nouvelles à travers ces différents
hebdos alors les nouvelles de
Rambouillet des de 50 ans de qui
diffusent chaque semaine un petit
élément pour permettre de remplir la
grille nous avons aussi les nouvelles
notamment de Versailles sur ces
différentes éditions il y aura des
indications pour répondre par exemple à
cette question qualifie les animaux tels
que les poissons batraciens et certaines
plantes vous avez la réponse vous
remplissez la petite grille qui se
trouve juste à côté voilà et puis comme
ça ensuite qu'est-ce qui a gagné alors
ensuite au-delà d'enrichir sa
connaissance et réfléchir sa
connaissance alors il y a pour les
scolaires et les centres aérés puisque
les scolaires et les centres aérés
participent des visites à thèmes
environnementales c'est à dire le le
parc la maison des aubenières dans le
parc de Chevreuse à Madrid l'Espace
Rambouillet la réserve de Saint-Quentin
si vous voulez tous ces espaces qui sont
effectivement des espaces
particulièrement intéressants nous avons
aussi des visites d'usines parce que
nous pensons que il est indispensable si
vous laissez pourquoi nous avons des
partenariats avec ADS avec PSA avec les
différentes entreprises du département
et que la Chambre de commerce est aussi
notre partenaire car nous tenons
beaucoup à ce que si vous voulez à faire
connaître ce milieu professionnel qui
nous semble très importants donc c'est à
destination on rappelle des 5 15 ans
vous vous rendez dans les différentes
gares de secteurs vous obtenez ce petit
fascicule et ensuite vous le remplissez
avec notamment les indications vous
l'avez mentionné et vous faites un joli
dessin et puis en décembre
qui a lieu au Palais des Congrès de
Versailles 12 avril et c'est jusqu'au 12
avril
juste une toute dernière question vous
trouvez où toute cette motivation cette
énergie parce que 30 ans d'activités au
sein de divine environnement toutes les
actions qu'on a mentionné tout à l'heure
vous avez un point de vue sur tous les
dossiers et en plus des actions à
destination des enfants écoutez je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas je viens
moi-même
un père promoteur et un oncle architecte
donc c'est des problématiques que j'ai
connues très jeunes j'ai été baignée
toute ma vie dans dans ces questions je
dois dire qu'elle me passionne et on a
la chance d'être une équipe très soudée
qui permet effectivement d'avancer et
d'avoir toujours des de nouvelles idées
merci et encore une fois bon
anniversaire donc à cette association
Évelyne environnement qui fête ses 30
ans en cette année 2013 on fait une
petite pause dans ce 7 8 on va revenir
sur l'affaire Dominici une affaire revue
et corrigée par les étudiants en droit
de l'Université de Versailles 50 ans ils
ont reconstitué ce procès en 1957 il
avait abouti à la condamnation à mort de
Gaston Dominici mais surprise elle issue
des play-dohries version 2013
l'accusation a été réfutée regardez
merci
alors Monsieur après lecture du serment
au tribunal de grande instance de
Versailles le procès de Gaston Dominici
commence l'accusé dans le box les
avocats ont revêtu leur toge les jurés
ont été désignés le président du jury
peut débuter son interrogatoire tout
semble réel sauf que Gaston domine ici a
déjà été jugé en 1957 vendredi dernier
l'association jurisprudence de
l'université Versailles Saint-Quentin
proposait une reconstitution de ce vieux
procès où les pardons ont toujours
persisté à l'époque accusé de triple
meurtres Gaston Dominici avait été
condamné à mort mais aujourd'hui tout
est encore possible il y a un véritable
doute et du coup je me suis laissé
convaincre qu'il était véritablement
innocent et je vais du coup essayer de
convaincre qu'il est lui-même innocent
pour juger cette affaire tout a été
reconstitué l'épreuve sont exposées et
des étudiants en droit joue le rôle de
l'accusé et des témoins déguisements et
accent comprise
comme ça donc pas de parents alcooliques
qui ont relevé la main sur vous
non des acteurs en tenue un public
bouche bée des improvisations qui font
sourire alors la justice serait-elle en
réalité du simple théâtre c'est beaucoup
de théâtre c'est beaucoup de comédie un
bon avocat s'il plaît doit être un très
bon orateur s'il veut remporter ses
dossiers ne pourra pas sinon un bon
orateur c'est peut-être ce qui avait
manqué à l'accusé à l'époque car les
jurés joués par des proches des élèves
ont déclaré cette fois-ci Gaston
Dominici non coupable